are you gonna win more than 22 games
next year i bet you 10 push-ups we're
gonna win more than 22 games next year
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're practicing today y'all man y'all
was killing me man i think i'll rise
here let's get up out here all right
[Music]
who's the hardest player to guard in the
nba oh man i'm definitely going to sing
uh kyrie irving or you know he actually
he scored um
60 points on us
[Music]
i thought you was gonna support me when
i said i think he's gonna make fun of us
oh my god
that has to be so hard are you gonna win
more than 22 games next year
hey eva that's messed up you would even
ask me that question i bet you ten
push-ups we're gonna win more than 22
games next year all right
i can each time i don't know if you can
do something yes i can once we win more
than 22 games you're gonna have to do
them i'm gonna see them all right okay
all right
do you believe in magic
i think i definitely believe in magic i
just seen a few magic tricks before so i
gotta say i'm a believer what about you
i don't why not
because i've seen how they do the magic
but even you are too young to not
believe in magic you believe in santa
claus
you see
elle man what you scrolling on your
phone over here doing the cars.com app
adds 50 000 new cars every day
helen you are 10 years old you cannot
drive so it's never too early to find
your perfect match
you know respect i can't even argue with
that
if you had a superpower would you rather
have the power to be invisible or have
the power to read other people's mind i
think i'd probably rather read people's
minds
i think you know
what you're ever getting mad about
seriously you rather be invisible yeah
well can i explain myself first you fit
yourself
you got robbed in the dunk contest right
absolutely not i did not deserve to win
that i'm not that good at dunker that's
really what it is
i'm telling you what i'm good at dunking
my dad is like he's pretty good at
dunking leg but so we did a trick shot
and we tried it took a long time but so
he threw it on the rim
he did a 360
not really a 360 but kind of like um
just a little spin and then he dunked it
can you teach me how to talk like i'm
from new york all right y'all vote for
lauren talking from new york all right
so i'm gonna get a few words y'all just
repeat after me look at the camera pay
after me
say you're
you're
yeah
say what's cracking
what's cracking yeah
say facts backs backs say facts
facts facts
now just do one of these
all right we good y'all from new york
now welcome new york city
[Music]
what's a chopped cheese
you know that's we like to call that a
magical sandwich that you know is only
really made right in new york a magical
sandwich magic see we get i told you
magic is real and you ain't never had
that so you've been to new york that's
why you saved me from this magic
[Music]
is your dad better at basketball than
you
absolutely not
i knew you would say that of course i'm
better right now than he ever was if you
do my daddy he would beat you you i
don't think your dad could beat me
i don't think he'd beat me yes he would
he practiced every single day after work
so do i
that is my word
why are you a 21 year old millionaire
with roommates those are my two best
friends and you know they just they help
me be very strict myself and make sure i
can maintain that schedule and so making
sure i'm just doing everything i need to
do every single day
and you know make sure i handle my
business all right guys this might help
me come up to real quick guys it was
cool riding with y'all man all right
okay
oh man see you guys later see ya
bye
oh
[Music]